und auf einmal kommt irgendwie so ein
blondes mädels sehr hübsch eigentlich zu
mir rüber und fängt so mit dem dicksten
bayerischen akzent an auf mich
einzureden greift zu meiner hand und so
hält über fotos wieder losgeht noch eine
kurze ansage wir wollten in dem video
euch einfach mal so erzählen was bei den
bio based games kommen so hinter den
kulissen passiert weil jeder über blogs
über die gamescom macht man kann also
wirklich erzählweise auf den altar
partys und drumherum passiert und wir
dachten uns einfach es war eigentlich
als coole sache euch das mal zu erzählen
so quasi bei ein bisschen stress
eigentlich nur die youtuber sehen ich
hoffe dass videos unterhaltsam für euch
falls ja shops kann in die kommentare
falls nein könnte auch über die
kommentarschreiber bisschen feedback
geben also ein kleines experiment ich
hoffe ihr wisst es wertzuschätzen und ja
jetzt film up services und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video in dem
ich lust auf einer couch sitze und euch
mal so ein bisschen erzähle was in den
letzten tagen hier passiert ist ja weil
wird sich alles darum drehen was wir
erlebt haben auf gamescom bio day ist
aber es wird nicht so langweilig sein
aller in halle 33 mann stand von isoft
haben allerdings gespielt sondern wir
erzählen euch wieso die knackigsten
momente unserer letzten fünf tage in
köln
vielleicht auch nicht so wie sich das
jetzt jeder vorstellen dass wir sogar
die besten games der gamescom leiharbeit
oder sowas wie so erlebt man auf der ein
oder anderen afterparty im bootshaus da
gibt es einige geschichten zu erzählen
und leute gab uns verstehen weil wir an
tag 1 mittwoch ich ziehe mich kann man
fast dass der knoten also die sache ist
warum wir da beide das jetzt auch machen
ist weil apple am freitag quasi bei mir
am donnerstag bis zu vier eingezogen
ich bin am mittwochmorgen bei mir um 6
uhr gleich auf mich dann hat man sport
gemacht den rübergefahren habe köln dann
bin ich in kürze angekommen haben ja
mittwoch und donnerstag was gedreht mit
wonach der wiederum hotel geplant und am
donnerstag dann bluten ab donnerstag
nutzern so weniger unterwegs die erste
party war ja quasi am donnerstagabend
das war
sonne youtube creator party in diesem
tower in köln wo man über köln drüber
gucken konnte dass das war schon relativ
geil aber es ging erhalten nur so bis 12
uhr möglich weil die dann schließen
mussten irgendwie und dann soweit weiter
irgendwann auch die university
das war schon krass da gab es noch
zwischen diesen parteien specials von so
ein paar leuten gegeneinander
ausgetragen
der dj hat er daraus gehauen da sind
jetzt aber keine ultra krassen sachen
passiert heile ultras sachen passiert ja
ich geb dir von stichwort rücke teile
people what happened dennoch ich weiß
nicht mal ganz genau ich leicht
angeheitert war ich weiß wird dass wir
ihnen wie hat ein settnik gurke auf
allen war wir müssen eigentlich bei
diesen ganzen geschichten den namen
zensiert
wir können nicht sagen wer was gemacht
hat ja einen etwas wie sogar sagen also
quasi newcomer aus dem bereich lifestyle
liefen am abend mit einer gurke für die
party jedoch diese gurke so krass
gefeiert weil er fast nichts genützt
dass bosch und das war einfach eine
party mitten in der pampa war kein
supermarkt aber nix oder einmal dass er
mit einer gurke oder damals die gurgel
genau warum so ein bisschen später
einmal so ich hab so getan als wenn ein
glied so und auf einmal wir haben sie so
guten komplett gepredigt und auf einmal
hat die person ist durchgebrochen oder
war für uns also weltsicht verfolgt und
darauf einmal ein weiterer newcomer oder
dergleichen newcomern und der leiste
zähle hat auch weil diese gurke einfach
so auf sich genommen und gefressen
das ist hat sich gar nicht so krass aber
in dem moment war es für uns die welt
genau diverse newcomer aus dem bereich
lifestyle dance fans geliefert aber cool
drauf also diverse bereich lifestyle
sind echt gut
der bio chemie im leben junger so gut
steht gut im leben die müssen nicht mal
mehr essen
an dem freitag sind wir dann eigentlich
relativ zeitnah auch zu dem video der
ist gefallen und sag ich mal so gegen 15
uhr wir sind die klassischen
frühaufsteher leute gerade während der
video des games company after partys
sind klar denn dem man nie spiel
unterwegs ist
der viereckige bett ist oder sorgen das
passiert nicht
5 also freitag wieder ist es halt nicht
viel passiert ich bin rumgelaufen ludwig
oben gelaufen
wir haben einmal gesehen und gefunden
weil den videodreh jetzt ist glaube ich
nicht so viel passiert am freitag
außerhalb diese kuchen tv ps freaks
sache dann können jetzt eigentlich zum
freitagabend springen da war nämlich im
bootshaus und habe nichts gefühlt 80
euro kritische großmutter war jetzt
geht's richtig los dem ist es bloß an
all dies nicht kennen ist sind club in
köln wo hauptsächlich elektro gespielt
wie wir sind dann halt jetzt bootshaus
angekommen irgendwann relativ spät er
sondern wir erstmal respekt leistungen
gesehen zudem durch jetzt eine
kurzzusammenfassung mehr zu sagen als
wir angekommen sind waren glaube ich
noch so 10 15 minuten auflegen oder so
und das einzige fähre gesehen habe war
dass sarah zu aufgelegt haben wieder
nebel so geklappt also war auch nicht
gegen revier das war ultra lustig in dem
moment ja ein großes reich jeder
irgendwie auch halt einige gewisse
lifestyle youtuber die sich dort
vielleicht eine flasche gekauft haben
ja auf jeden fall dass man die gespendet
ich will ja nicht so richtig den sinn
drin weil sie eine flasche und club
kostet 100 euro wenn du dir die
kiosksysteme euro am kiosk kaufen drei
nehmen haben sie etwas vielleicht schon
abgezogen ja
so hat der youtuber will so etwas nie
machen was eine anständige leute also
ich hab brauchen diese flasche league
folgen dahin wahlkarte kann ich aber
nicht die wahrheit
vergesst so einfach ich doch jetzt
einfach etwas weiter gaben hier passiert
ist ich tanze der tanzfläche hab meinen
spaß bei der musik musik war ganz in
ordnung
barbara cramm padam padam und auf einmal
kommt irgendwie so ein blondes mädchen
sehr hübsch ein nicht zu mir rüber und
fängt so mit dem dix den bayrischen
akzent an auf mich einzureden treibst du
meine hand im einst so dreh dich so
ich sehe was ich will einfach nur feiern
die kommt so ein dreh dich hier tätig
einfach so kompletter bullshit mittel
ich weiß ich hab noch nicht
sprachnachricht wo die dazwischen
scheint als ob wir standen zu dem
zeitpunkt im bus war um 2 54 freitag
nacht bzw
samstagmorgen und die stand an der bar
bevor der spanier nicht aufnehmen eine
freundin und wollte zu sagen sie ja mal
im bootshaus geht voll ab so schade dass
du dich hier bist und dann kam ich
glaube das war nimmt diese bayerische
und hat mir so viel dazwischen gefunkt
ferner spielt euch jetzt einfach mal die
sprachnachrichten
lernen
das ist es von mensch älter ich wollte
der spanier nur sagen ich bin nicht
betrunken und die sind viele fans weil
daran schon viele zuschauer also ich hab
noch nie im bootshaus und dann kam
wieder die ganze zeit an und ich wollte
ihnen was und dann war ich wieder ruhig
und da wollte ich etwas sage dann kam
wiederum geht also dieses mädel war
bester komiker sehe ich aber die war
echt komisch also übelster bei
wahrscheinlich hätten nichts gegen
bayern ist selbst das war ein
ursprünglich aber die war seltsam zurück
zur geschichte die karmann um ein dreh
dich dreh dich und nachdem ich dann
irgendwann verstanden hat was sie wollte
sie wollte dass die männer handeln wenn
ich michael oder meine sie sich immer
weiter die er konnte man nicht reden er
hat glaube ich seine leichten kratzer
der stand blood simple ist gleiche
gesagt das ging so 30 sekunden so dann
habe ich immer gesagt nee nee
und dann hab ich gesagt so da muss mir
zu bunt immer was mir zu bunt wird
geht's raus die frau ich gestört oder
wieder ich geh kurz raus
ich bin okay jetzt seine beine in die
hand und haus ab die versorgung stellen
wollte vielleicht verstehen was es
bedeutet wenn eine person das ingolstadt
kommt sowieso kaputt für bitte bleibt
gehe nicht weg doch das codewort für
bitte bleiben und geh nicht weg ist
bitte bleiben und gehen nicht weg und
nicht wir gehen dann abends aus dem klub
brauche als cool
da kommt einfach ein
botschaftsmitarbeiter anweist typ im
bootshaus t shirt richtiger klotz also
bei gebaut
da denkt man sich diesen töchter oder so
war wahrscheinlich auch oder hat
irgendwie so einen kleineren mann an der
hand und der typ hat gearbeitet er das
faktische an werk gearbeitet visum
also ja willst du mit uns mit komm
nächste diese jagd auf mich ins mittlere
selber klar dass ich zu gut dachte wieso
hast du nicht arbeiten dass die
symbolisch den arbeitsplatz habe ich den
dezent aber entschieden klar gemacht
dass ich da nicht mitkommen möchte aber
ich glaube da ist einfach ok labs ja
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich dieses haben
wir doch popstar video haben wir noch
papst dabei haben wir die noch ganze gar
nichts mehr
gar keine mehr 2 doch der gc aber darum
dass irgendein acht caps fragt und per
chat ist eine droge macht es nicht es
ist halt etwas aufputschen dass auf
jeden fall vor und darum geht diese
wieder ausschau nach münster was an
diesem abend passiert ist ihr müsst euch
diese szene vorstellen da draußen gibt
so tribünen so 123 sitzbänke
hintereinander so ansteigend ich sagen
ich höre auf der höchsten stufe mit alex
selbst in der mitte auf einmal kommt
dann irgend so ein tipp an dem auch
mega-star will diesen auch bisschen
komisch angezogen und wiese mitte
dreißig kommst du zu mir willst du hast
du zwei tage für mich
wir müssen wissen teile ist halt auch
was ist teile teil des lsd ja auch
irgendwie irgendwo synthetische droge
oder so was und warum ich bin ganz
normaler mensch in youtube ich bin
student ich sehe er ganz normal aus
leute und der typ kam an und frage mich
erstmal nach drogen wir waren alle
eigentlich todes nüchtern so und dann
kamen die tigers apple an so der sie
sich gerade in diese methode hat über
fitness und fragt ihn einfach mittendrin
so ob er drogen am steuer wie sie aber
so mit einem lader drogen und ich so ne
sorry ich hab keine total verwundert
natürlich damit hält man nicht immer so
ja aber hast du den teile da ich habe
ich nicht mal so es ist für meinen
kumpel nicht für mich und ich so
spaß die ja trotzdem keine fucking teile
da ja hier alles gut und will damit mir
einschlagen ich nehme so kommt gab echt
viele sachen wo wir uns alle gedacht
haben wo alter was passiert ja alles
aber das hätte man letztlich alles im
video packungen aber es ist viel
passiert
danke übrigens noch an die zuschauer für
diese süßigkeiten zu schauen
das war geil user dass es der shit auf
erden alter dankeschön dafür in diesem
sinne hotline macht's gut und schimmel
küsst los mochis